hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
so we're talking about courage is being
a virgin aerosol does a lot to say about
this and this is one of the ones that
he's actually most interested in in
develops does it to the fullest degree
of description we are going to think of
one device that's opposed to it right
what is that communist right is there
anything that's to the other extreme
courage kind of fake sort of courage
yeah yeah
when somebody is rash or foolhardy or
sometimes you say crazy right there
they're doing the things like a
courageous person but they're doing them
with a different motivation and it's
going to pan out differently in the
circumstances that they're doing now
where should we put these it really
depends on how we're looking at courage
and these vices are concerned with
theater but they're also concerned with
something that aerosol things isn't
certain way the opposite of fear
confidence which is also a feel and
emotion
now aerosol is not just talking about
having the emotions to second on what we
do with the emotions how we react but
the emotions are very important so if we
want to get it in terms of access of
fear then we would have to place the
power and we would place the rash person
over here the rash person may actually
lack through all together people who
lack fear altogether they're actually
very dangerous you want to stay away
from them because you know if you get
too mad at you you know there's nothing
to keep them from doing anything and
they'll probably get you if you're a
friend with them and all sorts of crazy
situations
himself particular with your courageous
but especially if you're you know coward
yourself and your thumbs not saying that
everybody you know has fully developed
one of these traits we could be sort of
wavering in between this tree to be
laboring over our characters aren't
always fixed at your age you have a lot
more control over changing your
character than somebody doesn't my age
twice roughly twice your age but we saw
it some different so fear and confidence
these courageous person feels fear and
confidence to do the right so a part of
it is about the right amount coward and
fuels too much right
the rash person feels not enough and
it's bad they are often still too much
coward
so is it just a matter of how much you
feel the intensity aerosol says no
there's other rights what are some of
the other things I could qualify
somebody being courageous they didn't
help you tell them apart from saying
someone's for such as the amount what
else okay this reason
aerosol will say that the courageous
person is courageous so that they can do
noble worthwhile things
this is actually going to help us strip
away some things that look like courage
from things that actually aren't
encouraged the foolhardy person might be
acting courageously because they want
everyone to think there's such a you
know tough guy or something like that
person is a coward might have all sorts
of motivations over this war so that's
one important unless right it is what
are the right things that come up with
respect
a little bit the right occasion
do we feel fear all the time I mean if
you do we've got a problem
all right probably need some hands-on
exact and empty anxiety medication if
you feel it all the time that you've
never feels here does that mean I don't
to knows what's there
we should feel fear towards the right
things so let's let's call this the
right behaviors and this is worthwhile
we have a little bit so the the person
who's rash doesn't feel fear when they
want to feel fear in situations where
it's natural to work what's right to
feel care the person who is a coward
they may feel fear when they want to
feel fear but they probably also feel
fear more intensely then and they will
also feel fear in occasions where they
should they're scared of things that
they shouldn't be afraid that's part of
what makes on the counter so let's think
about some of the things the Aristotle
talks about let's think about some of
the things that were afraid of he talks
about death that that's something that
scares you should not again you're
probably from the rash part because it's
natural to fear death we're lucky
because we live in a society where most
of us with past childhood lives but you
know if you want to get yourself killed
it wouldn't be hard walk out of the
night W right there people are driving
we're supposed to be driving 40 miles an
hour walk down to the part where
everybody's driving 60 and they're not
gonna stop and what would happen now I'm
an engineer you're by that that area
so push it you'd feel sense of fear
right even if there's no cars coming
because you know that's a dangerous area
right what are other things like that
benefit happens do any of you ever like
get a sense of vertigo
when you're in a high place you feel
like you might fall a lot you feel Kevin
sense of fear that's natural that's your
body saying get away from there
you might fall off don't go close to
that edge that's stupid you have to
overcome that in order to do things does
that happen to any of you if you're like
watching something in a movie or
somebody's bungee jumping or hang
gliding it happens to me my body kicks
in and I feel the kind of sense of
vertigo maybe that makes sense right
there are the things that were afraid of
Aristotle talks about poverty I think
there's something you can relate to most
people are a few steps away a few
paychecks away from losing it all even
our industrialized societies it's tough
to find people who actually saved up
enough where they could go without a job
for six months or a year you guys are
starting out many of you in a very tough
economy without a lot of tangible assets
to work with other than or positive
attitude skills internship that sort of
stuff that's that should be scared if it
is that's okay that's probably in just
right you know if it was the 90s and you
were like terrified about going on the
job market when there were tons and tons
of jobs and was super easy to get them
then if you were super afraid you might
but no I think it actually makes sense
to feel a sense of fear not to be
overcome by fear that's so that you
never said any resume time but to feel
sort of the healthy sense of perhaps
this thing that I don't want what
happened to me
disease he talks about that as well are
we afraid of diseases as much as not as
much as in previous societies right
where they got a lot of people that live
past some pretty scary diseases up there
whatever so the ones that you're worried
about Oh trust I wouldn't I wouldn't
have predicted that but yeah it takes
takes away a lot from you yeah yeah I
mean we now know a bit more about it but
treatment rates are better but people
are still dying what else none of your
going to get polio strong
yeah similar
these degenerative diseases you know how
we know that that people that are so
susceptible to them because people are
living longer while living long enough
they actually get sick of these things
that they wouldn't have to something
else would kill them before that if
heart disease we have all these
superbugs that are coming out that's
pretty scary think about the fact that
cholera some of those strains of that
are developing resistances getting
tougher to fight malaria people died
West Nile virus here the United States
Lyme's disease
well you can't kill it usually doesn't
but it screws you up pretty bad this is
one of the worst areas for that our dogs
have had it twice I had it once since
any material doesn't then I mean the
worst thing about that is then you have
to take that that doxycycline which
makes you sick for like a month after it
if you're afraid of that that's
reasonable that makes sense now
you know would it make sense for you to
like every time you go outside be
obsessive and checking your soft fur
protects no that would be a little bit
too much what else
so disease he says insult to you saying
about man in this case insult so to you
know one's wife and ones ones kids I
think we could generalize this more
widely for for anybody to be afraid of
other people hurting or maligning
their family their friends that is
something that is reasonable to feel a
sense of fear about the envy of others
our society is just as obvious as Greek
society once you know when you succeed
all of your friends going to be super
elated about your success or family
members some of them you ask someone no
and sometimes being successful can
actually make enemies of you well that's
reasonable to feel terrible - to a
certain degree so these are all things
that we fight fearful there are other
things that the Aristotle says we as
human beings find so fearful that it
would be your reaction all not to feel
the sense of fear towards them that it's
actually okay sometimes to be overcome
by fear you know what would be things
really really scary like that somebody
might be able to get you to do something
nice right now just like I'm going to do
this
Oh like I'm gonna ruin your sister
reveal not only occurred at torture
you know that would be extremely
extremely scary just thinking about
somebody doing terrible things to my
kids right now it makes me feel a sense
of being threatened of torture yourself
really really scared not like you know
just waterboarding torture which you
know isn't gonna kill you
but like pull your nails off kind of
torture that kind of stuff I'd be pretty
scared the air stuff would be pretty
scared you ought to be pretty scared if
you feel no sense of fear towards that
whatsoever you're probably laughing
something the sort of things that going
in horrible you know he's right
that's a mass stranger with a pick
whatever you like chevy changed a lot
scary hands what else they got knives
well that's pretty scary right
you haven't scared that sort of thing
sometimes we you know we make the
mistake of watching those movies right
before
that ones are the scariest I like you
know the ghost movies like the garage or
the ring or Paranormal Activity because
though but you know why those are so
scary because they suggest to you that
maybe something could come out of the TV
you know that while you're watching it
maybe just maybe something could happen
it is reasonable to be scared by those
things so aerosol says that what's
really key here is feeling the fear to
the right degree for the right reason on
the right occasions and then here's the
right response do you resist your fear
do you rely on the bit of confidence
that you do have to overcome that fear
now this is this is interesting because
this requires some active shorts doesn't
it on the person's part you have to do
something work on yourself before you
can actually resist what it is that
you're being called on to exist yeah you
know the pyridine for Aristotle is
actually battlefield courage he says
that I've been in its fullest sense it's
actually going out and fighting when you
know that puts your life at risk
remember these guys fighting for them
how many of you see those of those Greek
movies like troll I hear the 300 because
you know what that was like they had to
date a shield they had a bit of armor
they weren't covered in our work but
some some parts were armored and then
they'd have a spear and you know they
jab somebody with it or throw it and
then they did a sword and that was
pretty much it you had every other guy
around them had the same equipment and
all those guys over there are aiming at
pulling now and they're supposed to try
to kill them before that you know that
happens afraid I think it might be
Patton who said people say that you know
you should be willing to give your life
for your country
he said no no that's getting all along
you want to make that other pork mask
you can easily for kids country that's
it but that's pretty scary it's not like
shooting somebody and you even
firefights today those are pretty scary
two of it Amanda you can't just like
shoot somebody you got actually like Jam
a spear into him while he's trying to do
the same to you and there might be
another one of his buddies behind you
about to do the same that's pretty scary
a lot of people would throw away their
shields and take off and say screw this
you know I'll see you guys later
that would be showing confidence right
on the other hand being the Zerg and
running into battle that's that's full
heart there's something lacking in the
person who does that often times they
make terrible soldiers by the way people
who are rational or you can't rely on
them to actually follow orders they're
always looking for a fight never simple
extra says something really interesting
about this he says some of the people
who are over here actually they're
missing a sense of fear some of them are
actually secretly calories who are so
obsessed with how people view them that
they put on a really bold front to
appear courageous when they really are
and you can tell this because when the
going gets really really tough they they
cave whereas the courageous person
doesn't the courageous person is willing
to risk death risk dismemberment risk
all sorts of scary things for the sake
of of something good not just to make a
big name for themselves but to defend
some sort of good that needs to be
defended now I don't think a lot of us
are ever going to be on the bathtub
thank God right what are other ways
other venues in which
we do require courage let's think of
other ones that actually involve like
life and win first rather other venues
in which a person yeah could be either
so professions works just by police
officers yeah firefighters even unity
sometimes artistic yeah anybody who's
got to deal with the threat of disease
to so anyways nurses not so much doctors
cuz they've served in an athlete I'm
readers are on the front lines
battling disease making it personal as
anybody else any other bodily things
were being kind of bodily harm
and we have to we have to resist it we
have to resist our fear for the sake of
accomplishing something good yeah sorry
oh my god I think that's right even like
people doing research to like in labs
people trying to find shortest they're
exposed to different types of bacteria
all the time even I'll say in the micro
lab yeah there's bacteria that's true
the switch was a where clause like that
not everybody does that any like social
movement
like a better good like there's not
really the ask one particularly right
now that I can say it's dangerous I can
think that my school writers that's a
great example being willing to to take
on the danger I mean you know what the
one thing Martin Luther King he had to
have training sessions for the people
who are going to be the marchers before
they were allowed to march because he
knew that they were going to get their
heads cracked and dog sit down I'm gonna
get you know he's very high pressure
water cannons shot at them and they had
to be able to put up with that serious
thing without breaking it like just
lapsing into complete rage which I don't
like part time and so they put him
through goggles like that in order to
help them don't love them sense of
courage it was like a training in
virtual
that would be a great example a great
contemporary example displaying courage
that's not something you're going to be
able to do if you don't actually have
that because I'm certain the hell with
this
going back home now let's think about
more broadly not that physical harm but
other things that we're afraid of and
occasions where we would have to
ourselves out there and risk something
one of the things people risk or take
risks yeah okay yeah our reputations
when we especially vote for somebody
whether they're out yeah yeah takes
courage they're doing okay yeah
innovative innovation you know that
requires courage and then you know it's
the the same sort of things can apply
them you can befool our perspective is
right like telling your boss there's
ways to tell your boss that there's a
problem in the company that are less
alienating with the rash person might to
say look I just have to tell them what's
going on you don't want to do anything
that's very that requires if we don't do
that sort of thing to forgive in will
eventually become commas yeah now here's
where it gets very interesting with
virtues and vices Aristotle notes not
only do we have this like animals
structure the mean and the excesses the
people at the different accesses think
that they're actually in the middle
position and everybody else in the world
is screwed up so the rash person thinks
that everybody else is a coward
they call some Tomatoes you have to
designate the cowardly person thinks
everybody else is too risky they they do
things that they shouldn't do you know
they put themselves out there in cases
where they should they're there
exercising the right amount of prudence
and courage and handling the courageous
person is the only person in this this
spectrum who really has a good sense of
where not only where they fit in but
where other people fit so it's
interesting you have to develop a trait
through the action through choosing the
right thing and maybe spreading out over
here and you don't graduate swinging
here babies very fun over here
professionally swinging over here before
you end up seeing things correctly and
being able to help other people to in
the process because you know part of
what it takes to learn how to be
courageous is having other courageous
people to look to as models to help give
you some sort of idea what it looks like
in practice now the only other thing I'm
going to talk about with courage very
quickly Aristotle says that seeking or
risking death isn't always courageous if
one is now we talked about the raft
person who does that because they just
don't care or they're you know obsessed
with you know how people see those are
things like that there's other ways in
which one could be a coward and seek
death or risk death yeah and the
examples that he gives are to escape the
scenes of poverty when one is in love
one takes crazy risks that one shouldn't
and then if one is feeling you know
terrible pain or
Aristotle says it's actually something
more like Congress because one is so
afraid those pings are not getting what
one wants that one passes up you know
what would normally be very fearful our
staff and I think you could probably
substitute other things in there as well
any questions about courage and then
it's like oh the last thing I decide
there
Arizona thinks that there are some
people who risk death which is normally
a fearful thing right because they're
motivated by wanting to escape poverty
or they're in love or they are feeling
some some terrible sense of pain or side
and those are all motivators for action
and they lead the person to not fear
death so it kinda looks like they're
being courageous you know like we say
the people in law you know we all these
movies with people who are involved do
all sorts of crazy things that they
normally never do that's not really
courage Sacramento settled this position
one way to tell if a person is actually
courageous is it runs throughout their
entire approach things it's not just in
this one area like if you wouldn't be
you wouldn't be courageous of you're
holding courageous Network competitive
it at home right on a creative person
that has to be integrated any other
questions